hello je suis le styliste pour me
trouver tu rentres dans l'appli
messenger et utam le styliste dû cliquer
sur démarrer pour que notre aventure
commence
[Musique]
je t'attends rejoint moins vite sur
messenger reggiani je voudrais qu'on
accueille quand même venant sans
embûches troncs merci et ben franchement
c'était mieux tout à l'heure vous êtes
beaucoup plus sérieuse est nul c'est la
plus belle chemise que vous ayez joué au
yoyo salah il part avec un du budget h à
leurs besoins à vous la garde
merci en tout cas ça vous va très bien
mais regardez ça et c'est charles
ingalls sont derrière moi de sa mère de
charles ingalls et davy crockett quoi
c'est vrai et ben bravo en tout cas et
vous repartez comme ça tout ça c'est
cadeau c'est pour moi merci à vous a
fait d'autres cadeaux comme ça dans une
agence dans les émissions dont merci
venant ça les immersive au volant
[Musique]
usa